je commençais
la chaîne tout sécuritaire
je ne sais pas
m
pas cher
madame danielle tremblay bonjour je
n'étais pas là donc ça s'annonçait mal
ou bien ce voyage en fait des deux
aurait été intéressant d'aller en a pas
beaucoup d'écart et suscita pays qu'on
pouvait être reçue m'a approché par le
ca par part de fermat keats
j'ai toujours gardé un prêt de 100 et
puis avec tout ce qui s'est passé avec
les tremblements de terre l'aide
humanitaire ce qui est l homme qui avait
un heureux expo jeu le mexique mais
qu'est ce que je peux bien les faire là
alors vraiment je partais recul au
métier comme l'année passée qu'elle pas
été très mai car si voleurs qu'ils ont
pu finalement donné les derniers à
partir parce qu'on s'amuse trop alors je
m'étais dit que c'est de façon optimiste
mais ce n'est pas vraiment pas assez
comme ça
puis elle amado a été extrêmement c'est
la réalité
c'est un de vous plus long mandat comme
coopérante c'était cette semaine qu
est-ce que vous alliez faire venir y est
pas limitée au territoire de port au
prince
cap haïtien et là les agriculteurs
commencent à les aider c'était une
coopérative 37 jeunes agriculteurs
vraiment c'est un mandat ma partie parce
que première des choses les producteurs
est en période de sa manche de la
bourrée de semences à l'ordre de mettre
un consultant l'opam à que ces gens là
sont supers occupé déjà que l'année
passée ça faisait neuf mois de
sécheresse qui visait alors il n'était
pas pour marquer notre saison est rendu
sur place dès c'était difficile parce
que moi c'est un marketing mais quatre
potes produit 1 est en marche et parce
qu'il n'y a pas de production n'y a pas
eu de production n'est pas assez et
l'orne et 1 ça marche très difficile de
faire la mise en national produit qui
n'existe pas
comprenez vous dites la route de port au
prince aux gonaïves c'est un pet belles
routes beaux paysages mais des gonaïves
au cap
c'est une autre paire de manches et
notre dame et là on est en montagne et
très rocailleux
il ya des précipices incroyable je vais
faire la bolivie avec la route de la
mort mais ça c'est qui va aller
pratiquement et surtout que le chauffeur
et des ports à son affaire et donc ça
m'énervait un peu gta s'il devait y
avait des conseillers volontaire est
assis derrière et comme moi j'avais la
portière du côté trispeed évidemment que
je voyais tout ce qui fait vous voyez
votre avis oui enfin cet art du voyage
comme on dit les festayres et puis c'est
pas trop la fête avant parce qu'à
plusieurs reprises j'ai dû reprendre le
chauffeur parce que les classes n est
pas 4 des détours qui sont des courbes
là où on a des points morts il faut
annoncer notre venue pourquoi alors à
plusieurs reprises on est obligé de
reculer il y avait des camions avec des
changements de bouteilles de coca cola
ou des choses comme se plaisait à dire
qu'il peut avec ses toits qui doit
reculer alors la danse et du tourisme
pour les faire s'endurcit vous parlez de
coca cola mais il n'y a pas d'eau dans
les éviers à l'hôtel qui a l'air
magnifique mais ça ce sont les
apparences derrière l'image on voit
simplement guayabera magnifique
l'aménagement paysager féerique et tout
mais quand tu commences à gratter un peu
sous la surface
g data chambre ils ont pas accordé la
gaze à la bonbonne au four parce qu'on
doit nos propres pas la même chose pour
la tuyauterie pour olivier les toilettes
qui coule sans cesse les rats évidemment
et nos chambres qui donne sur le côté de
lavandières alors aussi le tapage à
temps plein vraiment et c'est ça qui
agressant à la longue c'est que on veut
intéresser les touristes à venir en
haïti mais de ce que j'ai vu qu'ils
étaient venus à cet hôtel là ils ont
déguerpi au bout de deux jours
des moustiques vous parlez des souris
qui dansent sur le toit la nuit vous
parlez du devoto vous avez le sentiment
de vibrer à mener durant la nuit vous et
bien une scène par exemple où il ya une
bibitte
on doit pas de bébé tenus au québec donc
d'un insecte un vilan insectes qui se
promène dans vos cheveux qui aboutit
quelque part et vous initier à l'hôpital
vraiment là j'ai pas fait avoir un
moment de folie un temps cela vraiment
j'étais assise au bar le crime après
quitté avec une autre faille en avalant
table son mandat de la journée puis tout
d'un coup je me suis engagé quelque
chose alors est ce que c'est ça que tu
essaies de jouer dans le récit de sa
peau
le lui demande je regarde mes cheveux
qu'est-ce qui se passe mb je voyais mes
yeux le coup d'arrêt au bas du dos qui
est ce qu'avec ça doit partir maintenant
fortement se transforme alors j'ai dit
non non il est logé 10 a pas de sens
alors je raterais prenez une douche me
met de l'eau dans l'oreille pour voir si
ces sommes seraient pas non alors on est
à la clé mais il m'aide c'est qu'il me
rende mon truc
à les voir là qu'est ce qui se passe
dans mon oreille et larressore avec un
espèce de fourmi qui s'est collé et qui
marchait toujours sur ce qu'on attaquait
alors 40 d'abord la vision qu'ils me
disent ça fait cher le kilo pour la
fourmi non c'est à fall a elle-aussi
discute avec les haïtiennes comme elle
cause par terre à l'occasion l'anah qui
était gentil elle me dit oh moi j'fais
ctq où l'imam à l'époque j'écoutais mon
lien s'est couchée par terre alors
souvent ça m'est arrivé d'avoir déformé
dans les oreilles alors elle lit le truc
c'est qu'il faut ski c'est dans la main
et ce même de lui rien dans l'oreille
alors board
bijoux dans les aurais pour les haïtiens
les trucs du métier vous apprenez donc
les trucs du métier
venant au travail
le tourisme le plaisir c'est une chose
mais important vous dites c'est le
premier mandat où j'ai envie de revenir
à la maison et un peu plus loin vous
écrivez quand ils m'ont montré leurs
outils pour cultiver la terre vous
parlez d'un groupe de trente sept
agriculteurs que vous êtes venus aider
directement les bras vous en tombent et
au sort des agriculteurs
alors je me suis dit bon il va y avoir
des instruments aratoires qui souhaitait
descendre mais le pen pioche qui
m'achètent là c'est tout à fait pas une
grosse agriculture madame la campagne
alors je doute ici pour aller les
indices et j'en ai pas mal plus
pratiques marketing
il ya défendu avant les boeufs dans le
futur parce que on commence par les
aider de l'eau ça prend de l'eau où on a
perdu des cultures aquos cap'ados derby
les régimes de bananes se plante par
plante cela dérive alors ça revient
d'année en année le même sens est mort
alors les fours acheter maintenant
d'autres ça m'a dit l'un d'eux ils ont
pas les moyens
alors comme je sais qu'ils n'ont pas
d'eau on peut commencer par ça mais vous
vous avez commencé par l'eau par l'autre
bout c'est-à-dire à travailler sur la
commercialisation du produit inexistant
qu'est ce que vous avez fait mais là on
a commencé par j'ai regardé auprès de
journée ça parce qu'il y avait des puits
qu'il y en a qui avaient des puits les
producteurs d'ananas dans la région
plusieurs noms sont avait certains puits
mais l'équipe ne vend pas assez gros
pour être capable de pomper plus profond
alors à la place j'ai fait des
recherches avec des fournisseurs
bien pour savoir un bel état capable de
trouver des gens pour réparer ce soft
n'a pas les moyens de chercher sur
internet tous d'aller voir caisse calais
depuis quelques coups tétouan mais alors
qui sert à rien c'est pas très utile
alors bon j'ai essayé d'aider de ce côté
là il ya des producteurs qui dans
d'autres régions avaient pas été aussi
attaqué par le manque d'eau alors j'ai
amené les autres buteurs qui étaient
dans la région que au sud je les amenais
visiter voir comment us en était sorti
parce qu'ils avaient fait des systèmes
d'irrigation mais il y en a qui a été
financée par des gouvernements allemand
et qui maintenant sont assaillis par les
femmes qui lavent leur linge là dedans
avec des produits détergents ce qui
augmente le ph donc les agriculteurs
peuvent s'en servir
on peut pas blâmer ces fameux lot de
porc marcher des kilomètres et des
kilomètres
quel canal passe devant la maison alors
c'est tellement des broutilles aux
gamins de choses qui on peut dépasser
d'avancé pour que ça fasse un sens pour
toute la communauté qui est seulement
par quel bout commencer atteint que si
vous étiez où je le suivis il ya trop de
1 g dans ce pays le sortons tous de
l'eau pendant un certain temps pour que
ces gens là se prennent en main c'est
dur c'est dur d'entendre samedi en l1 si
oui pis pour vous c'est encore plus dur
de le dire parce que là vous vous êtes
triste parce que tu vois cette réalité
là qui fait pas de sens de commencer des
trucs comme ça à l'envers et moi je me
suis fait l'argent des canadiens aussi
bon qu'il faudrait peut-être là dépassé
de façon consciencieuse
écoutez notre prochaine destination ce
sera plus heureux vous aurez plus de
succès c'est le burkina faso et c'est le
beurre de karité
donc on n'ajoute pas un mot de plus on
se retrouve
la semaine prochaine mais il ya quand
même des bonnes choses à utiliser les
enfants très courtois très polis ils
veulent beaucoup apprend les jeunes
surtout avec qui j'ai travaillé des
thèmes un besoin en grand besoin
d'apprendre la voyez j'ai quatre heures
par jour pour venir suivre la formation
ce matin 4 heures pour retourner à la
maison
un petit mobile est à la ramasse
l'oeuvre mon chapeau c'est des gens
extrêmement les haïtiens pour ça mais il
ya tellement de choses à faire
merci beaucoup daniel de nous avoir
montré à quoi ressemble visage de la
coopération dans certains pays
pas toujours pas toujours merci beaucoup